[Musique]
tu le connais pour tu parles
j'ai fais pipi chez lui certes à
montmartre plus d'un gosse de la butte a
pu dans le premier tiers de ce siècle
satisfaire un besoin naturel chez
francisque poulbot cela c'était toute
une époque
mais depuis poulbot si le sacré coeur
n'a pas changé la vie et le paysage
montmartrois eux ont bien évolué
[Musique]
les touristes se sont multipliés ils
viennent de tous les coins du monde et
la place du tertre est devenu un carreau
du temple où l'on vend du folklore à des
américains des allemands ou des suisses
qui ne demandent qu en acheter les
peintres eux mêmes
cédant à la facilité commerciale travail
en plein air ils mettront pour
satisfaire un public innocent la
dernière touche de couleur sous les yeux
même de leurs éventuels clients
ils peignent sans souci du temps des
poulbots moderniser up to take aux
coloris trop vif aux contours trop
cerner des poulbots des poétiser sans
humour ni gentillesse une faune qui
n'existe ni à montmartre ni ailleurs
leurs peintures est aussi imperméable
que leurs sentiments leurs inspirations
est aussi courte que leurs cheveux sont
longs
et dans tout cela nous lire et vous que
reste-t-il de francisque poulbot et bien
nous avons cherché
regardez explorer son nom ne figure sur
aucune plaque de rue sur aucune grille
de square à l'entrée d'eau qu'une
impasse au débouché d'aucune ruelle ne
parlons pas d'avenue votre boulevard
nous n'avons trouvé sa trace ni sur la
façade d'une maison ni sur le fronton de
quelques édifices pour montmartre
francisque poulbot n'a sans doute jamais
existé il occupe pourtant une très
grande place dans la mémoire de roland
dorgelès qui fut un de ses meilleurs
amis
et oui un des plus vieux des plus
anciens en tout cas cela fait maintenant
vingt ans qu'il nous a quittés et
vraiment n'oublie pas car ces deux
lettres c'était l'être le plus attachant
le plus charmant le plus insouciant qui
fut il n'a jamais quitté montmartre il a
commencé habitait au maquis pour finir
il est allé mourir dans le maquis quand
cette avenue lui juneau avait été tracée
et dans toute son existence il ne s'est
jamais éloigné à plus de 500 mètres du
moulin de la galette qui était son
premier centre d'attraction ils
n'étaient pas nés d'ailleurs à
montmartre il était né à saint-denis où
ses parents étaient instituteurs et là
il avait grandi avec les gosses de la
rue avec les gosses du ruisseau qui
devait dessiner toute sa vie tu sais la
maîtresse de la quatrième elle vient
d'avoir deux gosses à la fois tiens
j'avais pas qu'elle avait de marie
encore hamadi même les choux pommés pour
trouver un petit frère
je regardais dans tous dans l'apparent
salle par ici si tu trouvais une petite
soeur je marierai avec elle
mais tu trouveras rien ils se foutent de
toi est ce que c'est que ce jeu là où tu
meures porter cet oreiller sur ton lit
mais tu vas voir une poupée je vais vous
le dire moi les enfants ça se fait et je
sais pas comment un jour il a eu l'idée
d'envoyer un dessin un journal d'enfants
un journal gai de l'époque s'appelait le
pêle-mêle les envoyer ses premiers
croquis avec une lettre insolente sans
savoir où le disais je vous autorise à
les reproduire
le directeur du journal d'étonner de la
plante ce gamin un regard des cds cinq
attention a vu qu'il était bon il les a
pris ça donnait ddea poule bout et man 2
un peu confiance à ses parents son père
a dit 'oui' mais il faut que tu fasses
des études si tu veux devenir un grand
dessinateur un grand peintre faut faire
quelque chose
alors il a une idée son père par un de
ses amis qui était conseiller municipal
de saint denis il a obtenu une lettre
d'introduction pour jérôme peintre et
sculpteur célèbre de la fin du dernier
siècle monde de l'institut à monsieur
glorieux directeur de l'école des
beaux-arts un homme étonnant alors avec
sa lette de reproduction le bon
francisque poulbot est un et ce
présenter à l'école des beaux-arts et de
tomber sur le nombre de chats lutteurs
qui ont impressionné mais est ce que
monsieur le maître jérôme et là il va
bien je vais revenir à ton petit vieux
alors il a attendu
il se disait ce que je vais avoir le
courage de l'aborder il s'était répété
50 fois je devrais lui dire cher mais je
vous apporte une note de remous
recommande assure le monsieur machin etc
et je suis décidé à dessiner et à
répéter sa leçon il se trompait quand
enfin il entend à brouage c'était le
vieux maître qui arrivait comme il était
toujours sanglé dans sa redingote avec
une large décoration vos côtés et avec
redressant la tête et se cambrant alors
il s'est approché puis vraiment il n'a
pas vous c'est à dire non non il est
trop important pour moi je peux pas me
présenter à cet homme-là
le soir il est rentré chez lui il a dit
on n'a pas voulu de moi à l'école on a
dit qu'il y avait déjà trop de monde
eh bien mon dieu il serait pas mal
trouvé car au lieu de travailler à
l'école des beaux-arts et de dessiner
des nus académiques s'est dessinée il
s'est contenté de dessiner les croquis
de la rue comme premiers mètres eh bien
il a eu ce qu'il voyait sur les murs et
dont le cabaret brûlant qui sont venus
le voir ce soir devant le collège rollin
où il avait fait ses études et là ils
voyaient de beaux dessins qui trouve
étonnante
leur simplicité c'était ma foi des
dessins de toulouse lautrec c'était un
bon mètre pour un dessinateur
il s'en est inspiré et il s'est mis à
dessiner très librement
il a dix minutes ou même à saintes vaux
saint denis c'est trop loin de paris
je vais venir habiter paris et pour
poulbot paris c'était évidemment
montmartre la butte montmartre le maquis
entre la rue girardon et la rue
caulaincourt de l'herbe des marronniers
des becs de gaz du talent et de l'esprit
il ne faudra pas moins d'une guerre pour
faire pousser là des building et de deux
pour qui fleurissent le supermarché
touristique
mais lorsque poulbot s'y installa
c'était la campagne aux portes de la
ville le rêve la bohème et la liberté
le montmartre de poulbot c'est le monde
où la guinguette devient beuglant puis
cabaret où il suffit d'une enseigne
dessiné par andré gilles pour qu'on
baptise lapin agile l'auberge de la mère
adèle
[Musique]
c'est un monde de petits vignobles
encore prospères c'est un monde bien
vivants où les pavés retentissent du
claquement des galoches des enfants
c'est un monde qui commencent déjà à
entrer dans sa propre légende
[Musique]
c'est le cochon va faire marcher son
bateau dans la tienne et comme ils
pouvaient pas vivre sans les gosses si
les attirer chez lui il avait fait
construire un grand portique où on avait
un trapèze des anneaux des balançoires
et les gosses venait là il connaissait
les gosses de la rue lepic bien mieux
que le connaissait l'instituteur et le
directeur disaient tous ses secrets y
jouait à fait que s'amuser avec eux les
bourrées de gâteau il leur achetait des
galoches il était adoré par ses enfants
il les adorait lui aussi
[Musique]
les jeux des enfants et sa distraction
principal leur réflexion lui suggérer
des dessins une mine de dessin allait
naître deux mots recueillis réinventer
produit d'une observation et lavaur et
de ce monde naïf insouciant et joyeux
les gosses de la butte
je
[Musique]
sortez dans la rue c'était une kyrielle
de gosses qui l'avait dernière lui tenir
aujourd'hui au boulgour aujourd'hui
poulbot et le dimanche quand il voit des
sondes apéritif à la terrasse de manière
le qui sont la rue caulaincourt il y
avait toujours des petits qui menait aux
points de vie pour prendre un peu
grenadines avec de l'eau qui piquent et
les autres le regardent des jalousies
dont celui qui avait été élu foule
debout et être heureux là c'était parmi
ces gosses comme un grand gosse tu m'as
dit il et elle était vraiment le dieu
des enfants débutent les poulbots avait
bien une épouse ah oui oui il était même
plus marié que n'importe qui quand on se
mariait tous les ans avec la même femme
ce qui ajoute un peu de moralité il
avait eu l'idée de dire c'est un beau
jour tout de même célébré autant que son
lancer est vrai souvent et tous les ans
à la même date et se marier avec leona
qui se mettaient en blanc avec des
fleurs d'oranger lui en habit se faisait
frisés et tous les invités devaient se
fait se grimer se maquiller se costumer
alors les uns et être un garçon
d'honneur les autres en paillant paysans
d'acquérir et de la campagne avec un
palier une oie et un autre cinq cent dix
ans belle meilleur il y avait des oies
ville y avait il y avait de tout tout et
tous cortège burlesque aller dîner à
momas puis après on a les envoie au bois
en landau on était admiré par les
passants qui criaient vive la mariée
eh bien ça lui a pour seul lui a pas
porté bonheur car et quand il s'est
marié il s'est dit nous dessine moi ce
sera jamais aussi drôle quand s'est
marié pour de bon sera jamais aussi
drôle que le mariage d'autrefois et
cette fois là il s'est marié simple ans
et quatre témoins sans le dire à
personne
le cerveau qu'une ode et baroque était
dans l'air elle sautait dessus ainsi moi
j'avais l'idée d'élever en eau de
montmartre tout en voulant le big une
statue à isa eu ou non de la société d
un prévoyant de l'avenir gt1 prévoyant
de l'avenir et pour le beau aussi et
alors nous devions très bientôt rendent
hommage à ce grand prédécesseur qui
avait méprisé l'argent au point de
vendre son droit d'aînesse pour un prêt
de la lentille
on cite toujours en exemple dans la
bible qui est pourtant un livre sérieux
jacob et on ridiculise plutôt le bonnet
a eu en moi je suis pour et zaü caressa
hu avait un brave coeur ce combo est de
mon avis il a eu beau monde il aimait
bien son père sa mère et ne pensais pas
qu'il ne perdrai jamais triste jacob
était malade
le vieux et pas très bien portants il va
claquer d'espoir et je crois que si
j'étais le fils aîné ça vaudrait mieux
il a acheté le droit de son frère pour
un plat de lentilles ça prouve que son
frère était gourmand ce qui est une
qualité et que jacob était trop
prévoyant ce qui est un défaut pour moi
malheureusement cette société d aborder
à lui nous n'avons jamais pu élever mais
il ya une autre s'appuie qu'ils nous
doivent beaucoup
c'est la statue du général du maure
place malesherbes
les parisiens avoir au passage le père
d'alexandre dumas qui a été générale un
général courageux là sa statue elle
était là depuis des mois et des années
sans qu'on songe à l'inaugurer personnes
se déranger pour une allure et la statue
nous avons tout espoir dit qu'une
aujourd'hui besoin en ligne lyon et 100
personnes en août seuls on a fait une
fête ou pour le bo est arrivé en habit
man your man redingote du roi redingotes
il était merveilleux il jouait le préfet
ou un autre personnage important on a
les aléas gens qui étaient là de service
on dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe est
une inauguration d'un port prévu on a
couru au commissariat on apprend une
commissaire affolé qui a envoyé des
agents pour entretenir la foule et on a
procédé en grande pompe à l'inauguration
du général le général dumas on enlever
le droit que nous avions mis sur un
stade où ça a été très bien mais ça a
été tellement réussie que jamais depuis
l'administration n'a osé illustré
inauguré vraiment la statue du général
du bas en dix ans mais non nous en nous
couvrir de ridicule ça a été inaugurée
d'une fois si bien que une fois
seulement le général dumas a été
inaugurée c'est par poules mots tu
parles de la gueule qu'il a
[Musique]
travesti balle fait pour ceux ci gala
pour cela tout permettait à poulbot
d'oublier la réalité de ce mont martre
pauvres de toute cette misère excessive
qui autour de lui retombait sur des
innocents mais il ne s'agissait pas
d'oubli bien au contraire c'est l aide
et le secours que l'on trouvait chez lui
derrière le masque de l'insouciance et
du canular
[Musique]
au 13 avenue junot dans sa dernière
maison celle qu'il avait fait bâtir sur
ce terrain de l'ancien maquis il n'avait
rien oublié et les murs eux mêmes se
sont réhaussées des mosaïques colorées
par les têtes souriante de ces p'tits
poulbots dont il était le vrai père et
auquel il devait toute sa renommée
au premier étage la fenêtre de la
chambre de poulbot s'ouvre encore sur
les ailes du moulin de la galette
derniers survivants de l'ancien butte
montmartre
[Musique]
cette butte où tout se transforme
ou tout disparaît mais où cependant se
maintient un souffle poétique qui en
dépit des voitures et des bruits de la
ville ranime dans nos mémoires le
souvenir des mimi pinson des murs gère
des mac orlan des bruants et d max jacob
de tous iec et de toutes essences qui
l'enchanté qui ont vécu aimé et souffert
[Musique]
e
cet univers provincial au charme désuet
et à la tranquillité apparente pouvait
soudas a explosé sous l'éclat du rire et
de la truculence c'était la célèbre fête
des dom des dernières cartouches
le propriétaire de poulbot avait voulu
l'expulser or plus beau dans le jardin
avait fait construire à ses frais un
atelier dit tout de même je ne vais pas
me laisser des l'atelier que pour rien
que j'ai construit il m'embête ce type
je vais [ __ ] le feu à l'atelier dit on
va faire une fête des dernières
cartouches lagarde 70 et à la fin on
mettra le feu à la baraque soit dans à
ce que ça donnera les invitations ont
été lancées sous forme d'ordre de roue
tourne et intel devra se rendre avec son
pacte son paquetage et deux jours de
vivre chez francisque poulbot rues de
lorient pour fêter les pour fêter les
dernières cartouches
le propriétaire ayant appris ça a eu
peur et mon dieu il a accordé le
renouvellement du bail à poulbot mais
pour vous a dit ça n'est pas une raison
pour supprimer la fête la fête a eu lieu
c'est une fête étonnante tout le monde y
était arrivé de montparnasse et des
quatre coins de paris surtout de
montparnasse et de montmartre
les un costume et en guidant mobile aux
ongs regnard en non sa peur tout tous
les uniformes se présenter en soi moi
j'étais en garibaldiens tout le monde
s'était réuni là ça a été un cortège
invraisemblable et après 20 bien qu'il
pleut à verse
on se répandit dans les rues de
montmartre armée avec nos fusils lebel
rochas beau car nous avions mis d une
belle foot de chasse faux et fusils gras
et ont rencontré des gens qui revenaient
du cinéma a eu rivard des troupes dans
la rue il se doit et va à l'encrier
abdallah qui vive
aldo lounge fait feu les gens épouvanté
salades etc est si pauvre conseille pas
que la guerre a déclaré elle est rentrée
chez vous vivement lé genre épouvante et
ont dû passer une nuit d'horreur des
sports et croyons que la guerre était
réellement déclaré nous avons fait soyez
nous avons vu comme il convenait oui
hélas en 1913
ça nous a porté malheur et alors
nous à le matin on a pris le vandale
moulin de la galette d'assaut à la
baïonnette au milieu des hurlements et
des feux de bengale
eh bien mon dieu ça nous a pas porté
chance car un an après on repartait
cette fois avec de vrais fusils avec de
vrais uniforme et beaucoup des camarades
de la nuit des cas même des dernières
cartouches ne sont jamais revenues sans
l'officier les soldats nous aurait
peut-être rien fait dit moment la guerre
c'est donc contre les petites filles
c'est sa main heureusement que non pas
le taux est trop grand ils n'ont pas vu
mes mains là c'est un [ __ ]
je le mets des fleurs tout de même et ce
qui m'a peiné au moment de sa mort
c'est que les autorités officielles
n'ont pas cru devoir se déranger pour la
mort du moindre margoulins de la
politique on dérange des orateurs on
dérange dmz des orchestres on dérange
des drapeaux pour poulbot rien n'est pas
un discours pas une parole officiel pas
un représentant du ministère ou de la
ville de paris rien mais heureusement
toulon martres et elle a tout mon art
qu'il aimait et mon dieu il n'y a pas eu
de discours il a vu au dessus de sa tête
sur le pont caulaincourt l'activité
paris et le bourdonnement des voitures
et les cris des gosses ça vaut mieux que
tous les discours madame noyau morel
vous qui êtes exécutrice testamentaire
de madame poulbot vous pensez peut-être
que si poulbot n'a pas eu de problème
d'argent même la fin de sa vie il n'en
est pas de même pour sa veuve ou non pas
du tout parce que madame poulbot a eu de
graves ennuis financiers beaucoup de
soucis surtout à la fin de sa vie mais
comme bull boel
faisait passer bien au dessus des ennuis
financiers
toute la joie de vivre c'est à dire tout
ce que son mari avait apporté à tous car
pour elle sa joie de vivre était le
souvenir de poulbot le souvenir de ce
que pour le bo avait fait pour les
enfants de la butte elle ne vivait que
pour ça je crois qu'il était très désolé
du fait que dans la butte rien a rappelé
le souvenir de son mari
oui elle était désolée justement c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avait donné
par testament ce pouvoir de parler de
poulbot sous toutes les formes film lire
enfin tout ce qu tout ce qui pouvait
exister à l'époque actuelle pour faire
parler pour commémorer le souvenir de
poulbot parce qu'une organe avait été
fait jusque là
et ce n'était pas une personne à le
demander ne voulais pas le demander mais
elle aurait dit si heureuse qu'on lui
propose
et quand elle a rencontré mon mari qui
avait connu poulbot journal le journal
elle vraiment élevé a fait une très
grande confiance et à moi aussi bien sûr
puisque nous étions tout avec mon mari
associés dans cette idée est votre baril
s'était attaché à cette heure on pas le
rejoint et bien mon mari andré morel oui
c'était beaucoup attaché à cette oeuvre
au point que il a quitté ce plan très
jeune et
et sa dernière nuit a été uniquement par
les poulbots je vous avais repris le
flambeau
oui j'ai repris le flambeau gelé repris
pour pour le beau jeu les repris pour
madame poulbot gelé repris pour mon mari
j'ai repris pour l'oeuvre aussi parce
qu'une oeuvre comme celle de football ne
doit pas s'éteindre comme disait madame
poulbot pour le beau tout de même à son
nom dans le dictionnaire c'est un des
seuls nombre d'actionnaires au méthane
est ce parce que les poulbots cette
plaque grâce à l'action de madame oyo
morel va être apposée sur la maison de
l'avenue junot et peut-être que dans un
avenir prochain les poulbots qui
abandonne facilement leur cartable pour
aller glisser sur les rangs se donneront
rendez vous au coin d'une rue plus haut
vous devant un square poulbot poulbot
n'est plus mais les poulbots sont bien
vivants
[Musique]
m